nutritional information on tick tock can
be good or absolutely terrible and we're
about to react to all of it also thanks
to butcherbox for sponsoring this video
stay tuned to see how you can get free
ground beef for life
mac and cheese
that was hot you gotta be careful eating
that hot remember i have a whole video
on drinking hot fluids increase their
risk of developing esophageal cancer by
90 percent
i don't understand this like he just ate
some yummy mac and cheese and he's going
ham now
is that asmr honey i want it oh my god i
love honey so much it's not really
healthy to eat in large amounts but guys
honey has legitimate medical uses
oh it's so good you know there's also
medicinal honey like manuka honey can be
prescribed for wounds that are poorly
healing when i've worked at a wound care
center before in patients who had
multi-drug resistant bacterial skin
infections we gave them topical honey
and it worked it's incredible have you
ever wonder how koreans maintain their
good bodies even after a big feast like
this is that true like i don't know if
that's medically accurate we need to
drink this once a day they contain
garnisha cambogia and they work to stop
carbs from being transformed into fat
time out there was a very famous doctor
that decided to call this a miracle cure
that said you don't need to exercise you
don't need to diet just take this
supplement and it'll help you lose
weight it's poop never been proven in
humans the results have been mixed to
negative so stop promising people
miraculous cures even memorial sloan
kettering which is where my mom ended up
getting uh her cancer treatments before
she passed has like a whole page on this
we're gonna pop it up here to show that
the results do not show this thing works
bro why do you eat your fries before
your burger look the logic behind this
is fries or carbs and they're going to
process way faster than the protein
burger so i want the protein to fill me
up at night and make me feel food
i hate saying the word bro science but
if you're eating it four seconds apart
the way that it looks in your stomach is
so it doesn't matter if you eat this
bite first and this bite second in the
end
it's all like that
whoa is that a cougar
you know it's funny i always get the
cats wrong i'm like oh panther they're
like no cougar i'm like oh cool guards
like no panther i'm like oh puma they're
like no panther
i would not mess with that thing it
could be like a lynx i don't even know
there's so many cats
where's the cheeks i asked for extra
change i'm not gonna lie when my
cholesterol uh levels were through the
roof because i was ordering pizza with
extra cheese that's a surefire way to
get your cholesterol up times run it out
okay probably have to have a dermato
dermatologist chime in here but i'm
pretty sure the oils on the pizza also
not great for the face they probably
cause breakouts what did i miss in this
video why are we slapping ourselves with
cheese
this is a bottle of dr james expectorant
from the 1800s how did they get their
hands on that wow with the one cent
stamp on there it still has the original
label on it and it's completely full
it's completely full but it's so inert
it's crazy it says alcohol 13 you don't
think that alcohol has already um
expired no it's
when the sun shines on water and
evaporates you don't think all the
alcohol has evaporated from this bad boy
come on now would it evaporate if it's
been sealed yes unless it was kept in
like the most ideal condition the cork
based on the conditions and the humidity
will change shape and that will allow
some air to get in there as it says it
contains alcohol and opium and it's for
children 14 to 21 years old you know
what we were doing not that long ago and
some doctors still do and
in rare cases it might be okay given
codeine as a cough serum we have now
taken a pretty firm stance to say that
the risks outweigh the benefits for cody
it's an opioid back to the tic tocs in
just a second but first i want to talk
to you about butcher box as some of you
know i've completely transformed my diet
in the last year as i prepare for my
debut as a pro boxer i'm working out
twice a day and i have a very strict
nutritional schedule to make sure i'm in
fighting shape this could have easily
become a process of eating bland foods
but thanks to butcher box my meals have
been better than ever butcher box
delivers 100 grass-fed beef free-range
organic chicken wild caught seafood and
so much more directly to my door in
particular i've been enjoying their wild
alaskan sockeye salmon which is fresh
and flavorful while also being packed
full of nutrients butcher box only
sources from farmers and fishermen who
meet the highest standards of quality
and you can choose your box and delivery
frequency so you get the exact foods you
and your family love if you click the
link in the description right now
butcherbox is gonna give you free ground
beef for life that's right new members
will receive two pounds of grass-fed
ground beef for the lifetime of their
membership all right let's get back to
the tick tocks
why are my evil arch nemesis
back
you know like they do all these cap not
cap this is pure cap cap cap cap cap cap
cat
[Music]
they're putting crystals in here they're
just throwing everything in the book is
this sponsored by goop
rub on belly and thighs during the
waiting but i'm not gonna lie i might
rub it on my thighs because my thighs
have a problem maybe this can fix the
energy in my thighs
oh
oh
that was dull
i didn't expect that to be that cool
when kids say they don't drink water add
lemon juice cucumber
jelly beans what do you want your kids
to choke olive oil whipped cream
sprinkles tada so you just gave your
kids an olive
i
oily
understand ultimate diet hack this is a
little 25 cali marshmallow i hate the
word hack
all you need is five seconds in the
microwave and
dude
[Music]
okay that's not what happened that's a
lie that was deceptive video editing and
there's probably so much refined sugar
in there oh my god it's so easy to
overdo it with excess sugar that's how
your body starts getting confused that's
how it actually starts poisoning your
gut and when i say your gut i'm really
talking about the gut bacteria that live
in there by eating all that refined
sugar you're feeding and changing the
type of bacteria that's in your gut and
increasing the number of bacteria that
love sugar thereby changing like the gut
mind microbiome where it's encouraging
you to eat more and have sugar cravings
just be really careful like if you go
camping you have some marshmallows not
the end of the world
isn't that thing just like a pure sugar
cookie like just a ton of sugar same
point talking point as marshmallows lots
of refined sugar no bueno but if you're
doing it for a competition and your
life's on the line you better get to
licking by the way do you know why the
licking thing works it's because your
mouth has saliva in it saliva has
salivary amylase which is an enzyme that
breaks down carbohydrate sugars and the
parts that are the smallest meaning
where the cutouts are dissolve the
fastest therefore you're able to push
the cookie out with a beautiful star
five reasons you should do a juice
cleanse okay this is hard for me to
debunk because you should give your
digestive system a break from processed
food but you don't need to juice cleanse
in order to give it a break from
processed foods you can just eat
unprocessed foods which are whole foods
and healthy foods you like beet juice
eat beets you like orange juice eat
oranges why do they want to drink
everything just chew it you have teeth
two kick starts weight loss no you do
not need to kick start your weight loss
you know what eliminates toxins your
organs your organs clean out toxins
kidneys liver you have abuser boost
energy it doesn't even say boost energy
it says boots energy are you trying to
cut carbs but it's really hard to do get
a knife
i don't know why let me show you how in
segments in wedges in slices she took my
joke cutting carbs is hard use a knife
wow she literally stole my joke okay or
i stole hers
i think i've seen this video on my tick
tock before this is like an esophageal
dermal fistula where if you have a
connection between two parts of the body
you can create a fistula which
essentially creates a passageway i'm
turning vegan is he really
oh
oh wait what
so okay it looks like steak what does it
taste like though i have two simple
solutions for how to wake up happier i
wake up pretty miserable the last few
weeks training for boxing so let's see
what we got here take about 400
milligrams of magnesium glycinate
magnesium is the mineral responsible for
over 3 000 enzymes in your body if you
add a couple magnesium pills and a full
glass of water before bed you'll start
waking up feeling incredible
that last part why why make a promise
that if you add a glass of water maybe
you're gonna start feeling incredible my
friend walk into my medical office to my
patients who've been suffering with
insomnia for two years that are in tears
severe depression because of their
insomnia and make this promise and watch
them feel even more debilitated more
upset because your little life hack
didn't work stop the promises it truly
hurts people it's not the same thing to
say
magnesium has these actions in cells as
saying taking a bunch more magnesium
will make these processes better or
faster or more efficient the reality is
if you don't have the magnesium those
processes don't happen but it should be
talked about with their doctor not from
a random tick tock video promising you
success and probably selling you
supplements on the side
tap water healthy for us to drink let's
find out yes
i solved it yes now what i'm going to
take is some medical grade alkaline
water just so we have a different water
to compare and we'll test the ph we'll
see what the ph is for ourselves oh
thank god let's test that ph now in the
united states of america all tap comes
out alkaline-ish right and the reason is
because the federal government mandates
that it has to be like this they put
chlorine fluoride arsenic lead oh yeah
they put lead in your water bro do you
hear what you say sometimes they
actually limit how much arsenic and lead
ppm can be there i have a straw we'll
blow bubbles and we'll compare what is
chemical versus molecular these videos
they just take words that are scientific
chemical versus molecular here is just
three words that's it no meaning just
three words and what happens when we put
it inside of our body my friend here's
what happens when you put your alkaline
water inside my body it mixes with my
stomach acid which has a ph of two on
your little red acidic scale there and
it ends up being two because the stomach
acidity is very tightly controlled and
then it continues on this way down to
the gut and then it gets absorbed and it
enters the bloodstream and the
bloodstream's even more well-controlled
ph 7.35 to 7.45 even if the blood peach
range slightly comes out of that
slightly it can become lethal so your
little one ph difference in your little
water bottle there that you're charging
hundreds of dollars for is complete poo
poo every king here our boy liver king's
back eat your heart out primals he's
literally eating a beef heart when i was
watching the videos last time i didn't
realize that he was going to be
consuming all of the meats raw so i
didn't comment on it but you guys
rightfully pointed it out the reason we
cook our meats is because we want to
kill the bacteria that's found on them
in them when you consume them raw a lot
of times you'll be okay because your
stomach has hydrochloric acid your body
has an immune system but the problem is
the one time that that little listeria
salmonella it gets through you're gonna
have a really big problem i believe in
the hygienic theory like kids should
play in the mud like we need more
bacteria on us around us in us but this
is an unnecessary way to do it in my
opinion at least to recommend to
everyone to do because most people don't
know how their meats are processed they
don't know who's touching them and
because of that you just don't know what
kind of bacteria is on there so cook it
and be safe
i mentioned intermittent fasting in this
video but here's a whole video dedicated
to it huge thank you to butcherbox for
sponsoring this video remember if you
join now new members will receive two
pounds of grass-fed ground beef for the
lifetime of their membership as always
stay happy and healthy intermittent
fasting